I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office Ladies. Oh boy, this is a good episode of Office Ladies today. I'm so excited for you guys to hear it.
I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office Ladies. Oh boy, is this a good episode of Office Ladies today. I'm so excited for you guys to hear it.
I'm excited to listen to it. I'm going to listen to it over and over and over again. We're listening to ourselves right now. Today we're going to be talking about customer survey. It is season five, episode seven. It was written by Lester Lewis and directed by Stephen Merchant. The Stephen Merchant. Come on, you guys listening.
You know who Stephen Merchant is. Yeah, creator of The British Office. Come on. We got to talk to him, you guys. I was supposed to wait until fast-back queue, but I can't wait. I can't wait. We tried really hard to keep it together. We couldn't do it.
We couldn't do it. All right. We'll still go through the motions. Summary. Jim and Dwight received poor customer surveys, and they joined forces to uncover why. Were they really bad? Is something going on? Yeah, a little bit of a who done it.
Who done it? Meanwhile, Pam and Jim communicate all day long via teeny, tiny Bluetooth earpieces. And Andy and Angela make some wedding plan decisions. Oh, yes, they do. They get the best tintist in all the land. They do. I loved that so much. We got them.
We got them. We got them. All right. Fast-Fact number one. We shot this episode the week of September 8th, 2008. It was our 79th episode overall. And I got curious, like, how many episodes of Office Ladies have we done? Oh, my gosh.
How many have we done? This is our 83rd. You're kidding. That's bonkers, right? Wow. We're, like, zeroing in on the big 100 in both cases. Can we have a party? I think we can.
Sam, can we have a party? We sure can. Thank you, Sam. Sam, you can be head of the PPC for Office Ladies. Was it become a task for me? I mean, you got the coolest Christmas tree this year. Come on. That is very true.
You're head of the PPC. Yeah, Sam, if we could have a party because he's, like, the one person who's going to come. We don't have very many people that work on Office Ladies. I know. If Sam's not down, then we don't have much of a party. Pretty much it's Sam and Cassie. Cody, will you stop by?
Maybe Colin. Yeah. We got to get Iliana in. Oh, and Marissa. Yeah. Those are our peeps. And we still need to have Take Your Kid to Work Day because my kids really want to come in the studio.
We were just talking about it on the drive to school today about how they want to come because summer break. Oh, let's get them in here. Yeah. Okay, wait, this is a big episode. Well, Chitty Chat later. All right. We'll figure that out later.
Fast fact number two, Steven Merchant directed this episode. So he and Ricky Gervais created the British office. It ran on BBC Two for two seasons. They were six episodes each, and then they did a two-part Christmas special. They wrote and directed all of the episodes themselves. Yes. I mean. They would sit together with a dictaphone, right?
And they would talk out scenes and then transcribe them. They wrote the whole series, just the two of them. And then they let us make an American version. And then Steven directed this episode. And then he agreed to come on our podcast. Come on off this, ladies. Oh, my goodness. I mean, wow.
To prep us, before we listen to the interview, I thought we should go over a few facts about the British office and the American office. Oh, I like it. Okay, so the British office was set at a paper company called Wernham Hog, and it was located in Slough. The building that they used for the exterior of their show, it was located on Slough Trading Estate, and it was called the Crossbow House, but they tore it down in 2013. Oh.
So you can't visit it. When we do our England tour of office locations, we're not going to be able to see that one. Well, we might just have to go to the spot. Yeah. Okay. That'll be a great photo. You know what? I'll put it in our scrapbook.
Dunder Mifflin, on the other hand, was located in Scranton, and the exterior of our building was and still is located at Chandler Valley Studios on Santa Coy Street in Van Ice, California. You can take a picture with that one. You can. But as a nod to the British series, the address of Dunder Mifflin is listed as 1725 Slough Avenue. I know, I always love that. So sweet.
So sweet. It's even on the fake business cards. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Like Michael Scott had business cards. I might have taken one. I might have stolen one. It has that address.
Well, we will talk more about these two companies when we speak with Stephen. Should we get to it? Well, I have one more FastFact. Oh, my Lord. Okay. Let's do it. I know. I know.
I'm so excited. FastFact number three. This episode was written by Lester Lewis. Oh, yes. I found an interview with Lester where he talked a little bit about what it was like knowing that an episode he had written was going to be directed by Stephen Merchant. Oh, I love it. Can I hear it?
Yes. So he said that the story for this episode was already in place before Stephen was attached to Direct. So as he was writing it, luckily he had no idea that like one of the- Thank goodness. Yes. I wouldn't want that in my head. I would just want to like write what I was going to write without any pressure.
Yes. And then he was so nervous when he found out because, you know, the writer gets to walk around with the director for the whole week. They're together the whole time. It's like a very close relationship. Yeah. I mean, I would be pooping my pants. Yeah, a little bit.
But he said any nervousness that he felt totally disappeared when he met Stephen and that Stephen participated in the final rewrites of the script, he wished that Stephen Merchant could be with us for every single episode. Well, that's so sweet. Well, I couldn't agree more with that. I know. I mean, his energy is just fantastic. So smart, so funny and so kind.
Yeah. Well, Jenna, later when we break down the episode, I have a little story I want to share about Lester because he rescued me in a scene. Oh, he really did. But now we're going to take a break. And when we come back, Stephen Merchant. I can't believe it. I can't believe it.
Stephen, hello. Hi. Well, I should I feel like I should say hello office ladies. Oh, thank you. I love that. I am. I don't know if you've noticed in honor of both the British and the UK versions of the office, I am wearing my my Wernem Hogue baseball cap, which is, um, which is the
Dunder Mifflin of the UK. And then, but I have my Dunder Mifflin mug, which I believe was a crew gift for my cup of tea. So, um, you know, I'm just trying to pay homage to both, both sides of the Atlantic and both shows. You're awesome. We are. So awesome.
We love that. So much. Well, let's see. To kick things off. I thought that, and I'm sure you've been asked this a million times, Stephen, about meeting Ricky for the first time, but the reason I bring it up is because you mentioned Angela and I were rocking a duo. You're part of this duo with Ricky, but there are these people who, when we meet them, they
just change the course of our lives. I think back to, you know, Lenin meets McCartney, right? Like, what is that? Wow. I'm already an amazing company. This is exciting. As you said that, I'm like, I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
Wow. I'm so impressed with each other in the basketball episode, I didn't realize the impact I was going to have. That was our Lenin-McCartney moment, Angela. Oh, wow. So, Stephen, I know that you went into interview for a job to be Ricky's assistant at a radio station. You walk in the door, you meet this man, did you feel it?
Was there a spark? Was there a shift in the universe? Well, it was interesting because we, as you say, I did indeed go into a building to meet him. But he very quickly said, let's go to the pub for a pint of beer. Oh, my God. Oh, my God. And there aren't many bosses that do that.
He was hiring me for the job. So, I was immediately charmed by that. I thought that sort of seemed like the right approach. And we went down the road and had a pint and we got chatting and we seemed to have a lot of sort of common loves of things like music and comedy and stuff. So, we hit it off in that regard. But then he said something to me which I think was revealing. He said, listen, this was a radio station where we were both going to work.
And he said, listen, I don't know anything about radio. I've sweet talked my way into this job. I don't know what I'm doing. And you seemed to have had a little radio experience. If you do all the work, I'll make sure you have fun. And I, in need of a job, thought that sounds like a fair deal. And so, I joined the station with Ricky as essentially my boss and true to his word, he did not know what he was doing.
But we managed to find a sort of working relationship and after a little while, we were behind the scenes guys, but after a little while, they realized that our better asset was being on the radio. And once we went on the radio and we started talking and being kind of presenters, kind of like you guys, that was what I think we're all starting to make more sense. And I think that was where our, if you like, our sense of humor and our relationship with each other and our rapport. Or I think that's where it really began to develop sort of on the radio.
And, and then from then it was sort of, you know, it was plain sailing really, you know, and we just, and so much of what we, our experience, so much of sort of getting to know someone that you end up working with in that way is I think just, as I'm sure you guys discovered, it's just finding all the things you have in common. And I suppose the things you don't like, you know, and, and sort of deciding that these are the movies we like. These are the comedy we like. This is what we don't.
And I think that so much of the initial sort of partnering was that was finding that stuff, that common ground. Man, that is such a great story. And also I feel like something Angela and I have discovered in working together is like our strengths and weaknesses and how they, and our differences in our, in our work. We both have strong work ethics, but we work differently. What do you think were some of those things that made you and Ricky a good duo? Well, I think I was a little younger than Ricky.
And so I had a sort of youthful ambition and I kind of get up and go sort of dynamism. I mean, at the time we were working at this radio show and then I would go off and do stand up comedy in the evenings and things, whereas Ricky would sort of be home eating cheese with his girlfriend by sort of, you know, six PM. And I think, you know, he was older and he'd sort of settled into a certain groove. And I think I had this kind of eagerness to sort of make my stamp on the world. And I think, but at the same time, I think what Ricky had was just a sort of untapped kind of explosive brilliance that was just sort of waiting to be, to be sort of mind,
you know, and I think I had this slightly more kind of structured, slightly more rigid approach to things. And I think it was his sort of his wild spontaneity and my kind of slightly more, you know, by the book approach, I think kind of bringing those two things together sort of work well, you know, and I was able to kind of chaperone him through some of the more boring bits of writing, if you like, the working of the plots and all those sort of things. But at the same time, he had a kind of, he was just sort of smart. He was just wise about people and about, you know, he just, he was just older and so there
was a big brother quality to him that, that he could bring to it as well. So it was just a really interesting dynamic. We sort of supported each other and we kind of, I think, sparked each other's creativity in different ways. It was just a very exhilarating sort of time in both our lives, I think. Steven, you're my Jenna. You're my Jenna. Well, there you go.
I'm you, Steven, I'm, I'm the structure and the, the tasks and the, and Angela is the boom, boom, boom. I'm like, let's go grab a pint, let's, let's bounce some ideas off. And I'm like, I'll get a pint with you, but I'm bringing a notebook. Yeah. Exactly. Yeah. Exactly.
Well, I remember meeting you for the first time when you came to the set of the office early, early, Jenna, where was that? Where did, where did you guys meet? Was it the original Culver City set? Wasn't it? Steven, do you remember? I definitely think it was, it was a season one. Yeah.
And we weren't on the sound stages yet, right? We were in an actual office building. I think it was a real, that's right. It was a real, a real office above a real factory. Is that right? Or a real warehouse? Above a real warehouse. Yeah.
And didn't you guys, Steven, when you filmed the BBC version, weren't you in an actual office building as well? Weren't they like people working on the other side of the wall? That's very, that's absolutely true. So bizarrely, we were, we were within a studio complex, a small British TV studio, but we were not in the studio. We were in an actual office in the studio complex. And yes, as you say, there were people sort of who were kind of annoyed by the noise we
were making. And we're trying to get on with a job of work and we were there kind of, you know, running around and making noise and doing funny dances and whatever else. So yeah, so it was definitely very much a real office and it had all of the, the, the ups or pros and cons of that, I suppose, that it was, it felt real and we wanted it to feel very lived in and we wanted it to, we always wanted our version of the office to feel like a documentary that had sort of been made and then everyone forgot about it and it was just on a shelf somewhere at the BBC for like 10 years and someone dusted it off and was like,
put this on TV. So we wanted the whole thing to feel tired. The office should feel tired, the people, the clothes. We always were very excited when the plants that they had on the set were slightly dying. We liked that idea. It was the British, that British approach, you know, you reflect the weather by just making shows that are depressing and, and that was what that office had. It had a slightly tired feel because it had been a real place and it somehow stayed harder
to create that artificially when you build a set, you know, you're always striving for that. So it had that nice lived in quality, but, but obviously also restrictive to shoot in and a little bit difficult and, you know, and not much elbow room and, you know, so it was pros and cons. Right. And the former guys have talked about that, where we filmed the original, you know, set in Culver City was an actual office, so no walls moved and you couldn't pop anything
out and that really just added to the authenticity. But that's, that's where you guys met. You guys met for the pilot, maybe Jen or the table read. I remember doing a reading for you guys, gosh, I mean, and then I remember we ordered some food and had some lunch and just yes, but I think you were maybe shooting by then. I have a photo from that time, which feels like you're on the set and everybody's kind of, I'm sure you're maybe working and we were up and running by the time we actually visited. I felt like a lot of what we did initially was remote.
I know that Greg Daniels came and visited us in England and we sat with him for a couple of days and we sort of chewed the fat and try to talk about how, you know, try to give him a better insight into why we had chosen certain things for the British version and how they might translate to America and what the versions, what the equivalents would be in America. And it was fascinating to me because there were things which we assumed would be the same all over the world. For instance, the idea of an office, a group of people in an office going to a pub quiz
is quite a traditional idea here. You'd go to a trivia night, you know, as a group. And that I remember at the time, it felt like Greg, that wasn't as familiar to Greg. The idea of kind of the trivia night or the quiz night. And I guess maybe they are more common now, but I don't know that that was as... And it's interesting was when they did a version in France, it turns out that apparently on Friday night, at the end of the working day on a Friday, the champagne comes out in an office.
What? You know, where I guess in France, I think champagne is just like water in France, it's just everywhere. And I just thought it was fun, you know, just these interesting, you know, variations. Yeah, how many different countries is the office in now? There was a French version. There was a French-Canadian version. There was an Israeli version.
There was, I believe, a, I think it might have been an Indian version. Oh my gosh. And I think there's a South American version, but I forget where exactly in South America. But it was frustrating because they would send us copies of these, but of course none of them had subtitles. So it was just speaking in their local languages and I have no idea whether it was good or bad. It's got to just be so amazing, Steven, when you take a moment and sit in that, that you
went and grabbed a pint with this guy and all these years later, this idea that the two of you had is everywhere. It's everywhere. It's got to be just so humbling. It's like COVID-19. Oh no. Yeah, no, it's, no, I know what you mean, but I think, yes, but I think also what's exciting about that, and I think particularly one, when you guys began your version was that,
you know, we always were a fan of our show, but we could never watch it as an audience watches it because we were too immersed in it. We were there. We'd written it and we were just too involved and we couldn't get any distance from it. Whereas I remember when they would send the seasons of your show, the episodes of your show, I could watch it like a fan. It was like, I was like, I'm just enjoying it as a fan and not as a creator in the same way.
You know what I mean? It's very, very pleasurable. It's like your ideal show and then go off and make, have talented people make it and send it to you. You know what I mean? It's like sort of like an amazing kind of, you won a competition. You design a show and then talented people make it for many, many years. One of my favorite experiences was after we filmed the pilot, I was in London and you
and Ricky grabbed drinks with me at, is it called the Groucho Club? That's right. Yeah. Okay. And that was just so exciting. And then I was on the tube and I picked up what was like your version of TV guide and I looked in there and there was an article about how America was going to ruin the office. And there was a little picture of my face in a bubble comparing me to Lucy Davis.
And there were bubbles of all our faces talking about how we specifically outlining how we were each going to ruin the show. Yeah. I still know that I put it in a scrapbook. Let me tell you right now, Jenna, what really happened was Ricky and I had that manufactured specially and placed on the tube, planted on the tube in order to really make you buck up your ideas and do a good job. But it's funny you should say that because, because I remember that when that, when it
was first being discussed, as you say, there were a lot of things about, oh, America going to ruin the show. And that was when the show, your show started airing in the UK, it was kind of, oh, it's not as good as the British version. And then over time, it's become, the American version is far superior to the British version. This is the British, this is the way we do things here. You know what I mean? We're like, we, we kind of build you up and then we knock you down.
And so yeah, now very much the American version is kind of the much loved version, even by the British, the British press. And Ricky and I are seen as kind of, oh, those guys were tired of it. No. No. No. It's amazing. Maybe it'll come full circle.
Well, I remember meeting you guys on the, the new set when we moved, you know, way deep in the valley, Chandler Valley Studios. And I'll never forget, because you guys were coming for lunch and we were all super excited. And I think by now the supporting cast, we were, we were actually, we had real contracts. So I think I was a little braver to like come up and say hi, because maybe no one would fire me now because I was locked in. And you guys, we were going through the food line and the, the assistant director came up to me and said, Angela, you're the first talking head up after lunch.
And Ricky and Steven will be here. And I just went, like, I was like, oh, no, no, I just got the courage to say hi, please don't make me do a talking head in front of them. And Ricky said, oh, don't worry. I don't tisk too loudly and he did his finger and I was like, and then sort of broke into a cold sweat. But it was, I hope though that we, I hope ultimately, you know, I, I, I think we, we always ultimately tried to be supportive when we could.
We were kind of aware that it was like, there was this, I think just because we had British accidents and we'd come from a long way away, it was like, it was like the queen had come to visit. Yes. And we were aware of that. And I think trying to kind of, you know, make sure people realized we weren't here to judge or be mean. Oh no, you guys were great.
We were, we were just a buzz about having you guys on the set. And then when you came, I guess, you know, we're talking about customer survey this week. When you came to the set, I read that you were in the writer's room for weeks before we actually shot. Yes. Yes. Absolutely. Yeah.
And we always ask people how they got their job on the office. I think we know you started by creating, but how did you end up directing this particular episode? Do you remember? Well, I think whenever I visited, because I used to kind of visit whenever I was in LA, sometimes with Ricky and sometimes without, and I tried to come, you know, once a season and stop by. And I was always very, I just loved being in the writer's room.
Because in, you've got to remember in the UK, you know, Ricky and I wrote the show together and it was just us. And we didn't do a lot of episodes, but, you know, it felt like a lot of hard work. And it was, you know, it's just the two of us in this sort of cold London little tiny office. Whereas, when you come to an American writing room, you know, there's so many people. And it's just, it's just a really buzzy, exciting atmosphere. You're just, you're just with a lot of very talented, very smart people.
Ideas are sort of pinging around. And it's, it's a very different experience to the, to the British experience. And I always loved that. I was just always a fan of being in that environment. And so I think there had been conversations with Greg about sort of directing an episode and it just never worked out schedule-wise or I was always doing something with Ricky or I was doing something else in the UK. And for whatever reason, I had that little window of time.
And I think, so I think in a sense, that particular episode was the one that was up and when I could slot it in. And I had those few weeks ahead of it. And I just wanted, I just thought, well, I really, I love being in the writing room. I love being in that, that sort of environment. Let me come over and just absorb that. And I'm sort of really glad I did because I felt like I was able to contribute to the script of that episode.
And again, I can say just, I just really had a blast just seeing how it worked and seeing the ideas bouncing around the room and seeing how one idea becomes another and how jokes are improved. And like I say, not something I'd really experienced in the UK. And so it was, it was a learning curve for me as much as it was a, as much as it was a job, if you like. And do you remember any pitches from the room? I know there's one scene, the Mr. Butler scene, right?
That was, was loosely based off a situation you had at a job where you had to do the, the train up, right? That's right. That's right. I was working at a call center answering phones and we had to have training for a week beforehand. And one of the things we had to do was one person went in one room and called another trainee and one was the customer and one was the, the person working at the call center. And I figured that in order to maximize this and kind of get the most out of it, I thought
it would be useful to be sort of a challenging customer, you know, a little bit difficult or, or ask difficult questions or go quiet sometimes just because that's what I wanted to learn. Because it's figured, you know, you're never going to be able to just follow a script that someone always is going to be kind of difficult. So I started playing difficult customers for the other trainee. So I would be a little angry or whatever it would be. And eventually the guy in charge of the training took me aside and said, I can't have you do
this anymore because you're upsetting the other trainees with your, with your characters and with your questions and with your attitude. And anyway, so I'd always been very amused by that idea that, that in the course of that sort of training, you'd say you get so into the role that you'd sort of, it would overtake the training. Yeah. So I raised that as an idea and it just seemed like a funny idea to have Jim kind of deliberately needling Dwight in that way.
And I, some, some of the writers went off and kind of, and came back with that scene. And I, and I really was so happy with that. I thought it was absolutely fantastic. I thought it was a really funny spin on that idea. I thought the, when we shot it, I thought the three guys were just fantastic. I loved the fact that it was sort of longer than a lot of scenes are traditionally in, in the show that it just, it could just, we could just sit in that moment. And I think it's, in a way it sort of escalates and, and I just, I thought everyone kind of
knocked out of the park. And I'm sure there was a version of that, that we shot where either Steve or, or, I forget, I think it was Steve at the end, just said, we got the butt liquor account. Which I don't think we could ever squeeze into the finished cut, but there was a lot of sort of fun little improvs around the edges. And yeah, I just think when there's a sort of, when there's three great performers and a really funny idea like that, sort of given free reign, it's so thrilling to be there as a director and watch it happen.
And that was, I just, I was so satisfied with that, with that scene. It's so great. It's so great. It's so good. Well, Jenna, do you remember, I remember Stephen, when you were on set, we did rehearse scenes and we had sort of been rehearsing for technical, for camera. But I felt like when you were there, we rehearsed really sort of the meat of the scene and walked through the scene.
And I loved it. I had a few scenes with Andy and, and I had that scene with Dwight, you know, where basically we're going to get married on shrewd farms and I'm so happy and we're flirting and it's very weird. But we rehearsed and I, I wish that we had done more of that. And was that part of your routine when you guys filmed in England where you were rehearsing scenes before you shot them? We were.
And I think also what I think I probably brought with me, which was perhaps a bit unnecessary was I, I think I was still slightly hung up with the, this obsession with the kind of realism of, of what we tried to do in, and not that your show wasn't realistic, but I think we, you know, Rick and I had become very obsessed about realism and naturalism and what was real and what might happen and what might not happen. And I think actually it was a sort of unnecessary obsession because in the end it's a TV show and, and you know, it's just, you just sort of do what's the funniest and smartest thing to do.
And so I guess I was bringing with me this sort of this, we must, we must get to the truth of it, you know, and it's kind of like, wait a minute, aren't they wearing tiny little Bluetooth headsets that don't exist? Like why am I so hung up on, on the realism of this? You know, and, and so I think I was probably bringing in a necessary obsession with that, which I transposed from our version. And it's funny because even when I look back at our version, it's not, it's not realistic. I mean, there's lots of completely absurd moments, but for whatever reason we got that
in our head. So I think probably I was bringing a bit of that to it. And I think what I hadn't anticipated is just that you guys were so in a groove by that point that you didn't need rehearsal, you didn't need directing, you know, you could do it just standing on your head, you knew the characters way better than me. And you were just, you could just slip in and out of it so kind of effortlessly that you just didn't need that, that sort of, that, that rehearsal or that kind of, you know, attention to detail or whatever it is, you know, you could just, I could have just left you to
do it and come back after lunch and, you know, so I think it was just like I say, it was again, I think it's just slight naivety in a way about having not done, you know, American shows, particularly long running shows where at some point the cast are just so in sync with the show and the characters, they don't really need directing. Well, I don't, I agree with you that we were sort of like, we were a machine at this time, season five, but for me and Jenna and I and the cast have talked about this, when we did rehearse with you, it sort of grounded us back down and got us back into character. And not that we would step out of character because we could, like you said, we could go
right to Angela Martin, I know her, right? But I don't know for us as actors, we got really into it because it allowed us to, you know, like not to sound too actory, but have the moment that's the craft, right? And feel like you're really part of a production and kind of remind ourselves, oh yeah, we're here to do this really cool show that's a mockumentary and I don't know, I geeked out about it, Jenna. No, I agree with you, Angela, because by this time it was season five and, you know, at a certain point, it can feel like a comedy factory, a comedy TV show factory and we never
wanted that. And we, we did always try to come back to that place of authenticity. And when you came in in this season and really reminded us of that, I thought there was such a value in it and then also I was so grateful that you directed this episode, Stephen, because it ends with this big Jim Pam Alex art school guy scene. You talked about the tiny Bluetooth that actually did not work. They didn't exist at the time, they were like completely like made up, right? Yes.
But it's funny, isn't it? Now, because, you know, now with the airpods and these other things, you know, they're kind of standard issue, aren't they really? But at the time, that just seemed such a kind of crazy, that was probably, something I was probably hung up on at the time was like, what is this? Is this the thing? Yeah. Does this, can these exist?
And not only that, they probably would have been really expensive because no one, no one had them. Yes. And, and so we're, we would be shooting these scenes and it would either be like an AD reading the lines, so you'd be shooting John's side and I'm either off camera saying my lines so he can hear me, or it was an AD reading the lines. But in that last scene in particular, when Alex comes in to Pam at corporate and Jim can hear him giving her this pitch that she should not leave New York, I, I, we spent
hours on that. I mean, it felt like a whole day we spent on that and the, the script had like seven alternates to that scene. It was bonkers. Didn't, didn't want all, Jenna wasn't he like professing that he actually wanted to be in a relationship with you? Didn't, wasn't like there a huge spectrum of like what Alex was going to say to you? Yes.
It was that either the plea was, he actually had a line where he said, it's always been you Pam. Oh. I mean, that's heavy. And, and then there was this whole other version where he had no feelings for me. He was just really invested in my artistic life. And we were just, but did we shoot different versions? I can't, because I remember the discussion about that.
And I, and I feel like I was, it seemed odd to me the kind of big declaration of love. I, for some reason, I was uncomfortable with that, but what you don't remember as well is I wasn't entirely up to speed on what had already been being built within the season because obviously I'd only come in for that one episode. So, but I just, there was something for me that disquieted me about the declaration of love. I think partly because I, I think it was something, whenever the kind of Jim and Pam relationship is threatened, particularly once you've got together, I kind of, it just makes me uncomfortable.
It's like, it's like knowing that it's like your parents kind of the idea that your parents might get a divorce, it's sort of, I'm not, I just, it makes me sad, the kind of threat, the threat to the relationship just makes me sad. And so the idea, I don't know, I was worried that it was a sort of artificial jeopardy, like it didn't really count because there was no way that you were going to leave Jim. And so therefore we were sort of creating a phony drama, but, but that might be my missed memory. I don't remember, I don't, was it, was it, was it, was it nailed down by the time we
filmed it? Do you remember? The version where he professes his love was in the script. And John and I felt like you did. We thought, where is this coming from? We don't need this obstacle. And the one that appears in the show was an alternate. And so when we got to set, we were so excited that you were on our side.
And we could be like, guys, Steven Merchant, creator of the whole thing, thinks we're right. But it was still like this discussion. And I feel like for a while we tried to do this Frankenstein version where there was a little bit of his feelings and a little bit of art school, but ultimately I'm so glad that we picked the one that was picked. But having watched the show again in anticipation of this, it's a little odd that he declares, like you say, he's so invested in your art school because it feels like when he comes
into the office, that's right, he comes into your wherever you're working in order to, to kind of have a word with you. That definitely feels like he's going to declare his love because probably we filmed it thinking that was what was going to happen. And then by the time he gets into the little side room with you, he's like, you man, you got to stick with that art. And it's kind of, yeah, so it's a little odd, it's still probably a little Frankenstein-y. Well, it's also, it's also slightly out of the blue because we ended up cutting so much
of my art school, which at the time when we filmed this, we didn't know that scenes with Alex and, you know, he had given me a couple of art pep talks already, but they never made it. So it is a little jarring, but it sets up a really nice story for Pam and Jim, which is that, you know, what does the art really mean to her? What did this New York experience mean to her? And you know, and this is going to kind of haunt her for a while. And that, that part I like about the scene.
Yeah, you're right. You agree. And I, and I think, yes, it's that idea of, do you, you know, how, do you pursue a particular dream or do you be with the person you love and the two things pulling at each other is an interesting idea? Yeah. Well, I watched this episode again last night with my tweens, my 13 year olds. And just when Alex says, Hey, can I talk to you?
Just that, like the fact that he went to Dunder Mifflin corporate and sought her out to have a private conversation, they were like, Whoa. So it's, to me, it was a reminder that you don't have to do much to really convey emotion. And yes, Alex is saying you've got to give your art a shot. You can't do New York in three months, but it's clearly about so much more. And Jim can hear that. Jim knows. He knows that dude thing where you're, when he's like, Oh, he's into you.
And so for me, it was everything we needed. We didn't need anything more. There was something in the script that didn't make it in that made me laugh, which is that while Alex is talking, Jim says, cough if you still love me and I cough. Oh, that would have been great. Again, I don't want to take credit for things that weren't mine, but I feel like, maybe I'm wrong about this. But my instinct is that the little sort of tag on that when, when Dwight recognizes the
brand of Bluetooth in Jim's ear. I feel like I had some contribution to that because I felt like, I felt like the scene originally maybe just ended with the sort of the kind of dot, dot, dot and the drama of it. And I felt like it needed a little conclusion or something to just kind of take away from the, from the sort of emotion of it or the drama of it or something. And also sort of slightly resolve the Bluetooth idea. Yeah.
Yeah, that wasn't in the script, Steven. That, that, it was not. So that was clearly like an on the day thing. Yeah. A pitch. Yeah. I also loved the reveal of the coffee mugs and how in fact they had not gone to Kelly's party and how that's built within the episode.
And you talked a little bit on the DVD commentary, how you were so invested in shooting this coffee mug reveal. I was quite excited because there was a sort of, there was a sort of mystery element. And I quite liked that. It's funny how the project I'm working on the minute at the moment has a sort of thrillery element to it. It's the first time I've done that. And that, that, that little taster on the office of just sort of Jim is the detective
kind of piecing things together. It was very pleasing to me and sort of, and sort of seeing the Colombo, you know, seeing the evidence and the kind of the mind working. I don't know why I find that very, very fun and sort of sort of seeding the cups early on. And then the kind of the sort of when Jim looks around the room and he sees the mugs on the different desks and then he rushes to the, you know, just the idea of it having a little bit of a, a sort of, you know, like a kind of little bit of a sort of thrillery
NCIS quality to it or whatever. I just find that that was fun. It was a kind of nice, it was a different kind of energy, which I, which I find very pleasing to do, I remember. I took my mug. I have it. Smart. Why not?
I would hope that you've got all of your memorabilia from the show and it's just in a giant warehouse somewhere. I didn't get a mug. I was at art school. Yeah. You were at art school. Oh, well. Oh, Stephen, this was so great to reminisce about this episode with you and just reminisce
with you in general. Is there anything else that you would want to share? Well, the anything that occurred to me that I was always watching it the other night, the thing that I was suddenly reminded of, and I'm sure this was a trick that was used a great deal in your show and I, and I certainly we'd used it in our version. But I remembered there's a moment where Michael calls Jim in for his kind of customer, you know, survey appraisal and, and the camera kind of whips from Jim at his desk to Michael in the, in his office doorway, and then it whips back again to Jim at his desk.
And I remembered watching it again, I was suddenly reminded that those were, those were shot on two different days and that Steve had to leave for whatever reason. And we didn't have him for that following day. And so we shot him in the doorway and we whipped the camera off him. And then the following day we whipped back on to, to what John at his desk and then tied the two together in the, in the editing room. So it looks like it's happening for in real time. And I was just watching it kind of, and I was very pleased at how effective it was when
I watched it again. And I was like, hopefully only me and the editor know that's what happened there. I would have no idea. Yeah. Yeah. It was very, it was a very satisfying little trick. I remember Randall talking about the whip cut that this was their trick because because of you couldn't, so much of our footage is like a one or docu-style camera work.
It was really hard to cut, but if you did a whip, you could cut in a whip. And that was the way that they would be able to use two versions of a scene or something. That's right. Absolutely right. And it was, it's very satisfying to do it because it's sort of somehow you're playing a little trick on the audience and they don't realize, I don't know why that's so satisfying. Well I was just going to say over the course of the whole series, you were such a champion for Jim and Pam.
剪辑的时候真的很艰难，但如果你用甩切（whip），就可以在甩切里剪。他们就是通过这种方式在场景中用两个版本之类的。没错。完全正确。而且这样做非常有满足感，因为不知为何，你就像是在对观众开一个小玩笑，而他们并没有意识到，我不知道为什么这会这么有满足感。好吧，我正想说，在整部剧集的过程中，你一直是吉姆和帕姆的坚定支持者。
And I remember that so much. It was, you know, we talked about how that was true in this episode, but all the way to the end, you were always so invested in them. And I just say thank you because your voice in the writer's room was really meaningful. So thank you. Well, thank you. And thank you for, you know, such an amazing job and congratulations with your podcast. And I also, I wouldn't mind just saying a final thought, which was just about Lester,
我对此印象深刻。你知道的，我们之前谈过这一集里确实如此，但一直到最后，你对他们总是投入了那么多。我想说声谢谢，因为你在编剧室里的声音真的很重要。所以谢谢你。不，谢谢你。谢谢你带来了如此精彩的表演，也祝贺你的播客开播。还有，我不介意再发表一个最后的想法，就是关于莱斯特的，
who wrote that episode, who, you know, Lester Lewis, who so tragically died a few years after that. I only, you know, knew him for that one episode and that was the only time I'd worked with him, but he was such a lovely man. And I just, you know, and that's sort of whenever I think of that episode, it's kind of tinged with that bittersweet, you know, that bittersweet aftertaste, if you like. So yeah, a little reminder to him. Yeah.
他是那一集的编剧，你知道的，莱斯特·刘易斯（Lester Lewis），在几年后非常不幸地去世了。我只知道，你知道的，通过那一集认识他，那也是我唯一一次和他合作，但他是个非常可爱的人。我只是，你知道的，每当我想到那一集时，那种苦乐参半的感觉就会涌上心头，你知道的，如果你愿意的话，那种苦乐参半的余韵。所以，是的，借此对他表达一点缅怀。是的。
Yeah. We love Lester so much. Well, Stephen, I just want to say thank you. I mean, I feel like everyone in our cast was just like humbled that we got this job. We all felt like we won the lottery ticket. And you gave us that lottery ticket, you know, you and Ricky, and you forever changed our lives. Like I'm like, I'm the person that's quick to laugh and quick to tear up.
是的。我们非常爱莱斯特。好吧，史蒂芬，我只想说谢谢。我的意思是，我觉得我们剧组的每个人都对能得到这份工作感到既荣幸又谦卑。我们都觉得自己中了彩票。而你给了我们那张彩票，你知道的，你和瑞奇，你们永远改变了我们的生活。就像我一样，我是那种很容易笑、也很容易哭的人。
And what you gave us and how you changed our lives and our families, just from having this idea, I don't know, I will never be able to say thank you enough. So thank you. Well, that's very sweet of you. But again, I, you know, it's, I think Ricky and I feel very proud of our version, but also of the American version. I think for me, I grew up watching and loving American shows and I was hooked on, you know, MASH and then Cheers and then Roseanne.
而你给予我们的，以及你如何改变了我们的生活和家庭，仅仅因为有了这个想法，我不知道，我永远无法表达足够的感谢。所以谢谢你。好吧，你太贴心了。但再次说明，我，你知道的，我觉得瑞奇和我都为我们的版本感到非常骄傲，同时也为美国版感到骄傲。我想对我来说，我是看着并喜爱美国节目长大的，我迷上了，你知道的，MASH，然后是《干杯姐妹》（Cheers），然后是《罗斯anne》（Roseanne）。
And then the idea of sort of having my fingerprints on a show like yours, which stands in the lineage of those shows and is now as beloved by audiences as that, as those shows, it's just incredible. And that's a testament to you guys and all the cast and all the crew and all the writers. It's far, it's gone way beyond what Ricky and I did. It's like you mentioned about Frankenstein earlier, but, you know, to us, we've always thought of the offices, it's like Frankenstein's Monster and we kind of created this thing in the lab and it went off and rampaged around the world on its own, you know, without us.
然后，那种把我的指纹留在像你们这样的一档节目上的想法——它继承了那些节目的衣钵，并且现在也像那些节目一样深受观众喜爱——这简直是不可思议。这是对你们所有人、所有演员、所有剧组人员以及所有编剧的最好证明。它远远超出了瑞奇和我所做的事情。就像你刚才提到弗兰肯斯坦一样，但是，你知道的，对我们来说，我们一直认为办公室就像是弗兰肯斯坦的怪物，我们有点在实验室里创造了这个东西，然后它就自己跑出去，在全世界横冲直撞，你知道的，没有我们。
And the idea that the show is having this kind of, this sort of whole second life and, you know, audiences finding it again, I just think it's such a thrill and honor to be associated with it. So thank you. And will you tell us a little bit about the show that you're working on now, The Offenders? Yeah. No. No, goodbye.
而且这个节目能有这样一种全新的第二生命，你知道的，观众们再次发现了它，我只是觉得能与它联系在一起是如此令人兴奋和荣幸。所以谢谢你。你能跟我们聊聊你现在正在制作的新剧《罪犯》（The Offenders）吗？好啊。不。好吧，再见。
Oh dear. Come on. Well, it's interesting because it's a show that is about people doing community service. You know, when you get like a DUI or some minor crime and instead of sending you to jail, they give you 120 hours of picking up garbage at the side of the road or whatever. And my parents used to be, my parents didn't, they did not do DUIs. They were people that were in charge of offenders that did these days. And I just thought it was always an interesting idea, a good way of bringing a completely
噢天哪。行了。好吧，这很有趣，因为这是一部关于人们做社区服务的剧。你知道的，当你因酒驾或其他轻罪被捕时，他们不把你送进监狱，而是判你120个小时在路边捡垃圾什么的。我的父母以前是，我的父母不是，他们没有酒驾。他们是负责管理做这些日子的罪犯的人。我只是觉得这总是一个有趣的想法，一个把一个完全
disparate group of people together. And interestingly, it has parallels with the office in that regard because, you know, like with an office, those people only know each other because they work in that same environment and they fall in love and they hate each other and they fight and argue and it's the only thing that kind of keeps them together is because of that job and those four walls. And this was sort of a similar idea in a way is that although it has a bit more of a dramatic thrillery spine, the jumping off point is again, how do you bring an interesting bunch of characters together that wouldn't otherwise meet and sort of watch the sparks fly?
不同群体的人聚在一起的好方法。有趣的是，从这个角度来看，它与《办公室》有相似之处，因为，你知道的，就像在办公室里一样，这些人互相认识只是因为他们在同一个环境中工作，他们坠入爱河，互相憎恨，争吵不休，唯一把他们维系在一起的就是那份工作和那四面墙。这在某种程度上也是一个类似的想法，尽管它有更多戏剧性的惊悚主线，但切入点同样是：你如何把一群原本不会相遇的有趣角色聚在一起，然后看着火花四溅？
And so it shares some DNA with the office in that regard. But yes, we're sort of in the middle of filming it now and hopefully it will be out later in the year. And where can we find it? BBC and Amazon Studios? Is that right? Amazon Prime and BBC. Yes.
所以从这个角度来看，它与《办公室》共享了一些基因。不过是的，我们现在正处于拍摄的中期，希望它能在今年晚些时候上映。我们在哪里可以找到它？BBC和亚马逊工作室？是这样吗？亚马逊Prime和BBC。是的。
That's right. And it may, its name may change at some point. Who knows? Maybe it's cast will change. I don't know. But at the moment it's called The Offenders and yeah, and it's shaping up really nicely. I'm excited. Well, I want to throw something out there too because I'm a big fan of your film Fighting
没错。而且它，它的名字在某个时候可能会改变。谁知道呢？也许它的演员阵容会变。我不知道。但目前它叫《The Offenders》，是的，它正在成型，感觉真的很不错。我很兴奋。好吧，我也想抛出一个话题，因为我是你的电影《与我的家人并肩作战》的超级粉丝
with My Family. Thank you. It came out in 2019. I discovered it during the pandemic. It is so, so good. You wrote and directed it. So while you're waiting for The Offenders, check out Fighting with My Family. Thank you so much.
谢谢。它于2019年上映。我在大流行期间发现了它。它真的，真的是太棒了。你是编剧兼导演。所以，在你等待《The Offenders》的时候，去看看《与我的家人并肩作战》吧。非常感谢。
I'm very proud of that film. I think it turned out really nicely. So I appreciate it. Well, Stephen, this was just a joy. Yes. Thank you so much. It was wonderful. It's so great to reminisce.
我为那部电影感到非常骄傲。我认为它拍得非常不错。所以我很感激。好吧，史蒂芬，这真是一段快乐的时光。是的。非常感谢。这太美妙了。回忆过去真是太棒了。
It's really nice to talk about it. If I hadn't rewatched it, I realized I was completely forgotten so much of that and so much of the fun of shooting it. It was really pleasing to kind of go back and look at it again. Well, thank you so much, Stephen. Thank you so much for today. Thank you guys. Thanks so much.
谈论这些真的很好。如果我没有重新看一遍，我意识到自己已经完全忘记了那么多事情，以及拍摄时那么多的乐趣。回过头再去看看它，真的是一件很开心的事。好吧，非常感谢你，史蒂芬。非常感谢你今天的到来。谢谢你们。非常感谢。
Why don't we go from there? That was so great. I don't know, Angela, but I have to tell you, I was on a high for days after we did that interview. I know. Here's all you need to know about Stephen Merchant, by the way. He's the warmth and heart of this man. He really was the champion of Tim and Dawn on The British Show and of Jim and Pam on
我们从那开始好吗？那太棒了。我不知道，安吉拉，但我得告诉你，我们在做完那个采访后，我兴奋了好几天。我知道。顺便说一句，这就是你需要了解的关于史蒂芬·麦克 merchant 的全部：他这个人的温暖和内心。他真的是英国版中蒂姆和道恩的坚定支持者，也是我们版本中吉姆和帕姆的坚定支持者。
our show. And if you need an example of that, just look at how he wore his Wernem hog hat for a podcast. And it brought his coffee mug, his Dunder Mifflin coffee mug that he had tea in. We need to send him some Office Ladies merch. We have to. Yeah. Okay. All right.
如果你需要一个例子，只要看看他为播客戴上他的 Wernem hog 帽子就知道了。他还带了他的咖啡杯，那个装过茶的邓德米夫林咖啡杯。我们需要给他寄一些《办公室办公室》的周边。我们必须这么做。是的。好吧。好吧。
Well, should we break down this episode? Yes. Let's get to it. He opens with a very funny cold open. Dwight bursts into Michael's office to congratulate him on his engagement. Congratulations, Michael. And like punches him hard. I know.
那我们要不要来剖析一下这一集？好的。我们开始吧。他以一个非常搞笑的冷开场开场。德怀特冲进迈克尔的办公室，祝贺他订婚。恭喜你，迈克尔。然后狠狠地打了他的肚子。我知道。
I feel like this is how my kids would congratulate you, be like, you aced your test. Pow! Like Dwight is such a kid. Yeah. No, it's true. Daryl has a talking head. He just wants to make sure we all know that what we saw last week was true, that Michael is definitely not engaged.
我觉得这就像我的孩子们会祝贺你的方式，会说，你考试得了满分。砰！德怀特真像个小孩子。是的。不，是真的。达里尔有一个单人镜头（talking head）。他只是想确保我们都知道上周看到的是真的，迈克尔绝对没有订婚。
Yeah. In fact, he would help support his therapy. Might need a little help. Yeah. He's all worried about him. Well, there is a deleted scene where the gang asked Michael to tell him about the proposal moment. Oh.
是的。事实上，他会帮助支持他的心理治疗。可能需要一点帮助。是的。他一直在为他担心。好吧，有一个被删减的片段，大家让迈克尔跟他们讲讲求婚的时刻。哦。
And Michael just starts doing that thing to know where he just gets deeper and deeper into like a ridiculous lie. And it's so funny, Sam. Can you play it? Are you wasted? How did I propose? Let me see. Well, I drove her up to Nashua and I had the ring, big 10 carat diamond, which is beautiful.
然后迈克尔就开始玩那种把戏，越陷越深，编出一个荒谬的谎言。这太搞笑了，萨姆。你能放一下吗？你喝醉了吗？我是怎么求婚的？让我想想。嗯，我开车把她带到纳舒厄，我带着戒指，一颗10克拉的大钻石，非常漂亮。
And I got down on my hands and knees and a shooting star crossed overhead and it just lit up the diamond like a shooting star. And we were in a restaurant. And I put the diamond into a cheeseburger. Oh. And she took a bite and started to choke. So what do I do? I CPR training, go around, start doing the Heimlich.
然后我单膝跪地，一颗流星划过头顶，它把钻石照得像流星一样闪亮。我们在一家餐馆里。我把钻石放进了一个汉堡里。哦。她咬了一口，开始噎住了。所以我该怎么做？我有CPR培训，绕过去，开始做海姆立克急救法。
Perfect. The ring, 10 carat diamond, pops out of her mouth, hits her shrimp cocktail right onto her finger, million to one shot. All of the Greek people in the restaurant start screaming, up, which means congratulations. So what is this restaurant where they have ordered a cheeseburger and shrimp cocktail? And they're outside with a shooting star. And it's Greek. And it's Greek.
完美。这颗戒指，10克拉的钻石，从她嘴里弹出来，击中她的鲜虾鸡尾酒，正好落到她的手指上，百万分之一的几率。餐馆里的所有希腊人都开始尖叫，“up”，意思是恭喜。那么这是一家什么样的餐馆，他们会点汉堡和鲜虾鸡尾酒？而且他们在外面看着流星。而且它是希腊餐馆。而且它是希腊餐馆。
And you know that famous Greek shrimp cocktail under the shooting stars with a great cheeseburger. I mean, I just, you could just, if you get a chance, watch this deleted scene because you see him being like, and then this happened and, you know, 10 carat diamond. Yeah, I know. Wow. Wowzers. What I noticed in the episode is that everyone makes them call his mom and tell her the news. And she's like, she thinks he's lying again.
你知道那家著名的希腊餐馆，在流星下吃鲜虾鸡尾酒配美味汉堡。我的意思是，我只是，如果你有机会，看看这个被删减的片段，因为你看到他说：“然后发生了这个，你知道的，10克拉钻石。”是的，我知道。哇。哇塞。我在这一集里注意到的是，每个人都让迈克尔给他妈妈打电话告诉她这个消息。然后她觉得他又在撒谎了。
And he's like, why mom, come on. A couple of things. I don't know if you noticed the entire time he's on the phone with his mom, Mindy is hiding behind Phyllis' shoulder. You can only see her forehead. This is totally because Mindy was laughing. Yeah, she's laughing. Exactly.
他说：“妈妈，你怎么这样，拜托。”有几件事。我不知道你有没有注意到，当他跟他妈妈打电话时，明迪一直藏在菲利斯的肩膀后面。你只能看到她的额头。这完全是因为明迪在笑。是的，她在笑。没错。
We also had some fan questions from Sabrina, Hannah, and Paul who would like to know who voiced Michael's mom in the cold open. This was June Squibb, who is an amazing character actress. She was actually nominated for an Academy Award for Best Supporting Actress in 2014 for her role in the movie Nebraska. Oh my gosh. She also played Jack Nicholson's wife in the movie about Schmidt. She's so good.
我们还有来自萨布丽娜、汉娜和保罗的粉丝提问，他们想知道冷开场中迈克尔的妈妈是谁配音的。这是琼·斯奎布（June Squibb），她是一位非常了不起的性格演员。她实际上在2014年凭借在电影《内布拉斯加》中的角色获得了奥斯卡最佳女配角提名。噢天哪。她还在关于施密特的电影中扮演杰克·尼科尔森的妻子。她太棒了。
So good. She's so good. Yeah. Oh, we were so lucky. It was mom. Well, now we're getting into the episode. It's customer survey time. Yeah.
太棒了。她太棒了。是的。哦，我们太幸运了。那是妈妈。好吧，现在我们要进入这一集了。是客户满意度调查时间。是的。
Kelly brings Michael all the customer survey files and also a receipt to her bridesmaids dress that she had bought. That whole bit made me laugh so hard. He'll take care of it. Oh, yeah. He's got it. He just crumples it up and throws it in the trash. So the whole premise of the story is that Dwight, Jim, all the salespeople, they have
凯莉给迈克尔带来了所有的客户调查文件，还有她买的伴娘裙的收据。那段戏把我笑惨了。他会处理的。哦，是的。他能搞定。他直接把它揉成团扔进垃圾桶里了。所以这个故事的前提是，德怀特、吉姆，所有的销售人员，他们有
these customer surveys and if they do well, then they get bonuses and things like that, right? Right. So stakes are high. Jen, I have a question for you. Dwight, do you do the customer surveys? If you get a prompt on an app or an email or a receipt or if someone calls you because you've purchased something, do you do the customer surveys?
这些客户满意度调查，如果他们表现得好，就会得到奖金之类的好处，对吧？对。所以赌注很高。简，我有个问题问你。德怀特，你做客户调查吗？如果你在应用、电子邮件、收据上收到提示，或者如果有人因为你买了东西而打电话给你，你会做客户调查吗？
Very rarely, but occasionally, if I have a really great interaction with a salesperson, I want to give them a kudos. So I will actually go home with my receipt. They usually circle it and then I go take the survey and I say how great they were. This is totally why we're BFFs because I do that. I do the surveys, you guys. Every time? I try to.
极少数情况下会做，但偶尔，如果我跟销售人员有非常愉快的互动，我想给他们点个赞。所以我实际上会带着收据回家。他们通常会把它圈起来，然后我去完成调查，说他们有多棒。这绝对是我们成为死党的原因，因为我也这样做。我做调查，伙计们。每次都做？我尽量。
It's very time consuming. It really is. I was once on the phone with this guy. We had gotten an appliance delivery and then they do the setup and then they called to see how you liked their service, right? I was on the phone with the guy for 45 minutes. Saying what? Well, I did his survey and then we just had a heart to heart.
这非常花时间。确实如此。我曾经跟一个家伙通过电话。我们买了一个家电配送服务，然后他们进行安装，接着他们打电话看你是否喜欢他们的服务，对吧？我和那家伙通了45分钟电话。说什么呢？好吧，我做了他的调查，然后我们就开始交心了。
Josh came in and was like, are you still on the phone with the dishwasher guy? I said, I am. I did the survey and he told me a lot of people don't do them. Sometimes they hang up on him or sometimes they yell at him or sometimes they get very offended by the questions he asks. And they're just sort of standard questions. And I said, he was a really nice guy. I talked to him, you know, he'd had a tough few months and like.
乔希进来问：“你还在跟洗碗机那个家伙打电话吗？”我说：“对啊。我做了调查，他告诉我很多人不做。有时他们会挂断他的电话，有时会对他吼叫，或者有时会被他提出的问题冒犯到。”这些都只是一些标准问题。我说，他是个非常好的家伙。我和他聊了聊，你知道的，他过去几个月过得很艰难，诸如此类。
This is so you. Let me say I do the customer surveys that are online. Oh, yeah. I don't do like a phone call customer survey. Oh, I love a phone call customer survey. Yeah, that's you. I want to get to know you and anyway, this whole episode made me think about that. And I was like, I wonder if Jenna does them too.
这太符合你的风格了。让我说，我做的是线上的客户调查。哦，是的。我不会做那种电话客户调查。哦，我很喜欢电话客户调查。是的，那是你的风格。我想了解你，总之，整集都让我想到了这个。然后我想，不知道简是不是也这样做。
I do because I worked in that line of work and I know how like a good review boosts you up the ladder. It does. And I did as well. And so I think about that. Well, the other storyline going on here, Jim's going to have a talking head where it is revealed that he and Pam are wearing teeny, tiny Bluetooth earpieces. Yeah.
我做，因为我曾经从事过那类工作，我知道一个好评是如何在职级上提拔你的。确实如此。我也做过。所以我会考虑到这一点。好吧，这里正在进行的另一条故事线是，吉姆有一个单人镜头，其中透露他和帕姆戴着微小的蓝牙耳机。是的。
And this technology did not exist. No. The Mitsuhashi B400 is not a real thing. This is a fakey tech alert. Fakey tech alert. Yeah. We talked a little bit about this with Steven, how they were totally fake. So the way we did this was we shot John's side of these conversations first and I would
而且这项技术当时并不存在。没有。三桥B400（Mitsuhashi B400）不是真实存在的东西。这是一个虚假科技警报。虚假科技警报。是的。我们之前跟史蒂芬聊过一点这个，他们是如何完全是假的。所以我们拍这个的方式是，我们先拍约翰这些对话的那一部分，然后我会
be off camera reading my lines and then at the end of the week, we went to the corporate set and we shot my side of it and then John was off camera. And VEDA, our script supervisor, would have to take diligent notes because if there was an improvisation that we did, she would have to write it down so that we could remember to shoot my half of it when we moved over to corporate. Oh, man. So it was really complicated. It wasn't like there was a camera on him and a camera on me.
在镜头外读我的台词，然后在周末的时候，我们去公司办公室布景，拍我那部分，接着约翰在镜头外。我们的场记维达（VEDA）必须做勤勉的笔记，因为如果我们有即兴发挥，她必须把它写下来，这样当我们转移到公司办公室布景时，我们才能记得拍我那半部分。天哪。所以这真的很复杂。这不像是有一个摄像头对着他，另一个对着我。
Right. Yeah. That's how we did it. And by the way, I found out that this whole Bluetooth storyline was pitched by BJ Novak. I, of course, had to Google, what is actually the smallest headphone ever made? Oh. Yeah. According to the internet, you guys, and I don't know why I find this stuff interesting.
对。是的。我们就是这么拍的。顺便说一句，我发现这个整个蓝牙故事线是BJ·诺瓦克（BJ Novak）提出来的。我当然得去谷歌一下，历史上最小的耳机究竟是什么？哦。是的。根据互联网的说法，伙计们，我不知道为什么我发现这些东西很有趣。
This is like what's happened with us with office ladies. We talk about it. We see something. We're like, I want to know what is the smallest headphone? According to the internet, Swedish headphone maker Irinn kicked off its consumer electronic show in 2021 by revealing the A3, true wireless earbuds. And according to Irinn, they are the smallest and lightest headphones ever made. Sorry, Apple.
这就像我们在《办公室办公室》里发生的情况一样。我们谈论它。我们看到什么东西。我们就想：我想知道最小的耳机是什么？根据互联网的说法，瑞典耳机制造商Irinn在2021年的消费电子展上推出了A3真无线耳机。据Irinn称，它们是有史以来最小、最轻的耳机。对不起了，苹果。
Are they expensive? Do you know? I looked it up as like 190 bucks. What? For the smallest? For the smallest. But are they the best? Don't know that.
它们贵吗？你知道吗？我查了一下，大约190美元。什么？最小的？为了最小的。但它们是最好的吗？不知道这个。
Yeah. Don't know that, guys. Mm-hmm. Just telling you, Irinn claims to have the smallest. Now it's time for Dwight to find out how he did on his survey. And I have what I'd like to call a new catchphrase alert. What is it? Sam, can you play it?
是的，不知道这个，伙计们。嗯哼。我只是告诉你，Irinn声称拥有最小的耳机。现在是德怀特了解他在调查中表现的时候了。我有一个想称之为“新口头禅警报”的东西。是什么？萨姆，你能放一下吗？
Alrighty, Dwighty. Alrighty, Dwighty. It's my new catchphrase. I love it. I'm going to say it. Alrighty, Dwighty. What you got, Jenna? Well, I'll tell you, Dwight doesn't do well on his survey.
好啦，德怀特。好啦，德怀特。这是我的新口头禅。我喜欢。我要说这个。好啦，德怀特。你有什么要说的，简？好吧，我告诉你，德怀特的调查结果并不好。
No. And Michael's not joking. Even though Dwight has that queasy feeling that he gets when he sometimes is hearing a joke. Yeah. But he's not laughing. He can't be sure because he can't see himself. But yeah, it's very upsetting, but guess who else doesn't get a good review?
没有。而且迈克尔不是在开玩笑。尽管德怀特有一种恶心的感觉，当他有时听到笑话时就会有这种感觉。是的。但他没有笑。他无法确定，因为他看不到自己。但是，是的，这非常令人沮丧，不过你猜还有谁的评价也不好？
Jim. That's right. Yeah. He is arrogant and smudge. Lot of smudgeness. Yeah. Now, Jim turns off his little Bluetooth. Yeah.
吉姆。没错。是的。他又傲慢又自大（smudge）。有很多自大感。是的。现在，吉姆关掉了他的小蓝牙。是的。
Pam's like, what? What's happening? Yeah. And then he has a talking head where he reveals some pretty big news that he was counting on this bonus because he's going to buy his parents' house. Pam doesn't know this. And also, clearly, it's going to put him in debt because he says, you know, he's going to buy something he can't really afford.
帕姆问：怎么了？发生了什么？是的。然后他有一个单人镜头，在镜头中透露了一些相当重大的消息，他一直指望这笔奖金，因为他打算买下他父母的房子。帕姆并不知道这件事。而且很明显，这会让他负债累累，因为他说，你知道的，他要买一件他实际上负担不起的东西。
But he's also retiring his parents. Yeah. I guess they need the money from the house sale to retire. Then he gets on the phone with Pam. He tells her about the bad review. But not about the house. How do we feel about that? Am I opening a can of worms?
但他也要让父母退休。是的。我猜他们需要卖房子的钱来退休。然后他给帕姆打电话。他告诉她差评的事。但没有提房子的事。我们对此作何感想？我是不是捅了马蜂窝？
I mean, you have that look on your face where you know exactly how you feel about it. I don't know why you're asking me. You just turned red. I know. I know because this is going to play out. And... Well, you feel like a home purchase is a two-hander, not a one-hander. It's a big life moment.
我的意思是，你脸上那种表情说明你非常清楚自己的感受。你为什么还要问我。你的脸刚刚变红了。我知道。我知道，因为接下来事情会发展。而且……好吧，你觉得买房是两个人的事，而不是一个人的事。这是生活中的一个重大时刻。
And not just because they're going to live in it together and I think that people should pick out their living space if they're going to live in it, but also because it's a financial burden. It has just revealed this is going to burden him and then also Pam. And I think that something of that gravity you should speak about with your partner before you do it. I personally don't find large financial purchases that I then have to live in to be a romantic gesture.
不仅是因为他们要一起住在里面，而且我认为如果人们要住在某个居住空间里，应该由双方共同挑选，还因为它是一个经济负担。这刚刚透露出这会给他带来负担，进而也会给帕姆带来负担。我认为如此重大的事情，在你做决定之前应该先和你的伴侣商量。我个人并不认为我随后不得不住在里面的巨额经济消费是一种浪漫的姿态。
I probably shouldn't have bought you that RV. I do love the RV, Angela. And I wouldn't have had the table be exactly where it is, but I can live with it. I loved it. Thank you. I put the title in your name. How are those payments? We're kidding.
我大概不应该给你买那辆房车。我确实很喜欢那辆房车，安吉拉。而且我不会让桌子正好放在那个位置，但我能接受。我很喜欢。谢谢你。我把房产证写在你的名下了。那些分期付款怎么样？我们在开玩笑。
I didn't buy her an RV. I didn't buy her an RV. But yeah, I think this kind of moment is what we call the two-hander, guys. It's a two-hander life moment. Yeah. And I think this sort of speaks a little bit to where, you know, Pam was so heavily criticized for Alex's attention on her that she never reciprocated, right, in this art school story. But there's not a lot of criticism of, like, how Jim is partnering.
我没有给她买房车。我没有给她买房车。但是，是的，我认为这种时刻就是我们所说的“两个人的事”，伙计们。这是生活中需要两个人共同面对的时刻。是的。而且我认为这在某种程度上说明了，你知道的，帕姆因为亚历克斯对她的关注而受到了那么多的批评，而她在艺术学校的故事里从未对此作出回应，对吧？但对于吉姆是如何作为合作伙伴的，并没有太多的批评。
And that's sort of where, I don't know, he gets a pass maybe because he's so, like, charming and it's seen as, like, romantic. Well, some people might see it as romantic that he's going to provide a home. But I think... But he's not really because it's a financial burden. Well, I said, but I had a but coming, which is also that, you know, when you're partnering with someone in life, the word is partner, right? Yeah.
这就是那种，我不知道，他也许得到了宽恕，因为他太迷人了，这被视为是浪漫的。好吧，有些人可能会认为他要提供一个家是浪漫的。但我觉得……但实际上并不是，因为这是个经济负担。好吧，我说，但我有一个“但是”要说，那就是，当你与生活中的某人结为伴侣时，这个词就是伴侣，对吧？是的。
It's not soloing. I'm not soloing with you. I'm partnering with you. And Pam might have said, you know what? Why don't we live in one of our apartments and save money for a bit? Or she might have said, listen, I get it. I love your parents. I want your parents to be able to retire.
不是单干。我不是在跟你单干。我是你的伴侣。帕姆可能会说：“你知道吗？为什么我们不先住在我们的其中一套公寓里，存一段时间的钱呢？”或者她可能会说：“听着，我懂。我爱你的父母。我希望你的父母能够退休。
I agree to take on this financial burden to provide your parents with a great retirement. I'm in. That's right. But she never... She never got the chance. She never got the chance. Yeah. Because there was some soloing and not some partnering.
我同意承担这个经济负担，为你父母提供一个美好的退休生活。我加入。”没错。但她从来没有……她从来没有机会。她从来没有机会。是的。因为有人在单干，而不是在合作。
Yeah. Yeah. Let's talk about what Andy's up to. He goes to get some coffee, but he can't find his mug because Jim's using it. It's his face. But is it? I mean, smile. Smile like the mug.
是的。是的。我们来聊聊安迪在忙什么。他去喝咖啡，但找不到自己的杯子，因为吉姆在用它。那是他的脸。但真的是吗？我是说，笑。像杯子一样笑。
That was so funny. That made me laugh so hard. Jenna, what do I have here in my hands? You guys, Angela has her mug with the star and her little severe face. I took it at the end of the week. Am I like the office klepto? I pull on, took it. It has sat on my desk at home for 15 years and I keep my pencils and stuff in it.
那太搞笑了。把我笑惨了。简，我手里拿的是什么？伙计们，安吉拉拿着她那个带有星星和严肃表情的杯子。我在周末结束时把它拿走了。我是不是办公室的小偷？我伸手把它拿走了。它在家里我的桌子上放了15年，我把铅笔之类的东西放在里面。
And I washed it out and brought it here today so I could drink out of it. So cool. In honor of the episode, Sam, do you see it? You're head of the PPC, you need to clock things like this. It's wonderful. Okay. Thank you. I don't have one.
我把它洗干净了，今天带到这里来，这样我就可以用它喝水了。太酷了。为了向这一集致敬，萨姆，你看到了吗？你是PPC的负责人，你需要注意这种事情。这太棒了。好的。谢谢。我没有。
You don't have one. That is not wonderful. Thank you. You do have a mug though with the edge on it. I do have that thanks to you, Angela. I don't think we talked about that on the pod. We haven't. All right.
你没有。那可一点都不棒。谢谢。不过你确实有一个带边缘的杯子。多亏了你，安吉拉，我确实有那个杯子。我觉得我们在播客里没聊过这个。我们没聊过。好吧。
I'll share. Angela got me a mug from The Edge, my favorite movie. I made it guys. I went on a website and I made it. It took you months. It has a picture of Anthony Hopkins and Alec Baldwin and then it has a picture of the bear and then it has the quote, what one man can do, another can do. And I gave it to her as a birthday gift.
我来分享一下。安吉拉给我买了一个来自《边缘》（The Edge）的杯子，那是我的最爱电影。是我做的，伙计们。我上了个网站，自己做的。这花了你几个月的时间。上面有安东尼·霍普金斯和亚历克·鲍德温的照片，然后还有熊的照片，接着还有那句台词：“一个人能做到的事，另一个人也能做到。”我把它当成生日礼物送给她了。
Yes. And that is the actual quote from the movie, even though I say what one man has done, another can do. I looked it up. I got it right. No, you got it right. You got it right. And now Jenna can drink her mug with either the bear facing her or Anthony Hopkins and
是的。那确实是电影里的台词，尽管我说的是“一个人做过的事，另一个人也能做”。我查过了。我没记错。不，你记对了。你记对了。现在简可以用她的杯子喝水了，不管是熊对着她，还是安东尼·霍普金斯和
Alec Baldwin. And I use it on days when I need to get fired up. When we're writing our book and I know like I have a tough day of writing ahead and maybe I just, I'm not, oh, I just can't get into it. I'll get that mug, Angela, and I'll pour coffee in it and I'll look at that bear and I'll be like, I'm going to slay this bear today. The quote from the movie is, we're going to kill a mother f***ing bear today. The bear is the book.
亚历克·鲍德温。我在需要打鸡血的日子里会用它。当我们正在写书，我知道接下来有一天的写作硬仗要打，也许我只是，我不在状态，“哦，我就是进入不了状态。”我会拿出那个杯子，安吉拉，我会把咖啡倒进去，看着那只熊，然后我会想：“我今天要干掉这只熊。”电影里的台词是：“我们今天要去杀一头他妈的熊。”熊就是这本书。
The bear is the book. The bear is whatever you need to conquer in the day. Not today. The bear stares at me, not today bear. Not today bear. I love my mug. Or not today Anthony. Who's Anthony?
熊就是这本书。熊就是你今天需要征服的任何东西。今天不行。熊盯着我，今天不行，熊。今天不行，熊。我爱我的杯子。或者说今天不行，安东尼。谁是安东尼？
Anthony Hopkins. Charles. Charles. You mean Charles. Charles. Well, Jim says, why don't you use the Snoopy mug? And Pam's like, no, that's my mug, but it's not even her mug. Her mug is the pink mug.
安东尼·霍普金斯。查尔斯。查尔斯。你是说查尔斯。查尔斯。好吧，吉姆说：“你为什么不用史努比的杯子？”帕姆说：“不，那是我的杯子，但这甚至不是她的杯子。”她的杯子是粉红色的杯子。
I know. So I wrote here in my notes, wait, did Pam bring her pink mug to art school? Maybe Pam brought her pink mug to art school. Snoopy is her backup mug. Yeah. I love that. This is more mug talk than you ever thought you might hear. There's going to be more too, so just buckle in for that later.
我知道。所以我在这里的笔记里写了：等等，难道帕姆把她的粉红杯子带去艺术学校了？也许帕姆把她的粉红杯子带去艺术学校了。史努比是她的备用杯子。是的。我喜欢这样。这比你想象中听到的关于杯子的讨论要多得多。后面还会有更多，所以系好安全带，等下还要听呢。
Also, Andy would like you to know about landing the greatest dentist for the wedding. Do you mean the Shangri-La Tint to celebrate your wedding with excellence? I screen grabbed it. That's what the website says. And let me just tell you a little bit about this tint, you guys. It's two stories, and heated, and it has a bridal suite for his bridal suite. It's really simple and tasteful, a two-story tint. You know, it's the same tint as that Giuliani used for his first and third weddings.
另外，安迪想让你知道他为婚礼找到了最棒的帐篷。你是说香格里拉帐篷（Shangri-La Tint），以卓越来庆祝你的婚礼吗？我截屏了。网站上就是这么写的。让我跟你们简单讲讲这个帐篷，伙计们。它是两层的，有暖气，并且有一个新娘套房的新娘套房。它非常简单高雅，是一个两层的帐篷。你知道，这跟朱利安尼（Giuliani）在他的第一场和第三场婚礼上用的是同一个帐篷。
But Nana Mimi can't be in canvas that long. Angela's not having it. No. No, no, no, no. Well, I have to share with you guys this scene between Angela and Andy. I couldn't do it. I literally couldn't do it. It's at 10 minutes, 10 seconds.
但是娜娜米米（Nana Mimi）可不能在帆布里待那么久。安吉拉可不依。不。不，不，不，不。好吧，我得跟你们分享一下安吉拉和安迪之间的这场戏。我做不到。我真的做不到。在10分10秒的时候。
Angela Martin has to say to Andy, you can have your tint. But only if it's in a field, a hand-tealed field. You still can't say it. I tried my hardest. Just now you said hand-tealed field. No, I didn't. I was trying so hard. You said tealed.
安吉拉·马丁必须对安迪说：你可以要你的帐篷。但前提是它必须在田野里，一块人工耕耘的田野里（hand-tealed field）。你还是说不对。我尽力了。你刚才说的是“hand-tealed field”。没有，我没有。我太努力了。你说的是“tealed”。
Did I say tealed? Like tealed like the color. Okay, well. It's supposed to be tilled, hand-tealed field. Okay, so here's what Angela could not do on the day. What I just read to you guys was what was exactly in the script, right? And if you watch the show, you know that's not what I say. Because I think we did like 13 takes.
我说“tealed”了吗？像“teal”（青色）那个词。好吧。应该是“tilled”（耕种过的），“hand-tilled field”（人工耕耘的田野）。好吧，所以这就是安吉拉当时做不到的事情。我刚刚读给你们听的就是剧本里原本的内容，对吧？如果你看过这部剧，你就知道这不是我说的。因为我想我们大概拍了13条。
My Southern kryptonite is a vowel in front of an L. You might remember filthy emails. I couldn't say those. So I kept saying a hand-tealed field, hand-tealed field. So many times that Lester came over to me, who's so sweet, and he said, Angela, it's hand-tealed field, tilled, hand-tealed, like untill, I can't say that, what happens to me? I cannot say this word. And I said, and I looked at him, and I like looked at his lips as he said it, I was trying
我的南方发音克星就是L音前面的元音。你们可能还记得“filthy emails”（肮脏的电子邮件）。我就是说不出来。所以我一直说成“hand-tealed field”、“hand-tealed field”。说了太多遍，以至于莱斯特走到我身边，他那么温柔，他说：“安吉拉，那是‘hand-tilled field’，tilled，hand-tilled，就像until（直到）那样。”我就是说不出口，我这是怎么了？我就是说不出这个词。我说，我看着他，当他说的时候我看着他的嘴唇，我真的
so hard. Stephen Merchant is the director, I'm sweating bullets here. So I was like, okay, okay, I got it, I got it, hand-tealed field. And so I said, you can have your tint, but only in, if it's in a field, a hand-tealed field, hand-tealed field, hand-tealed field. And it was like a disaster. Lester came over, I'll never forget, he sort of crouched down by my desk and whispered to me, Angela, why don't you just say a hand-plowed field?
拼命在试。史蒂芬·麦克 merchant 是导演，我当时急得直冒汗。所以我说：“好吧，好吧，我懂了，我懂了，hand-tealed field。”结果我说：“你可以要你的帐篷，但只能在，如果它在田野里，hand-tealed field，hand-tealed field，hand-tealed field。”这简直是一场灾难。莱斯特走过来，我永远不会忘记，他蹲在我的办公桌旁，对我说：“安吉拉，你为什么不说‘hand-plowed field’（人工犁过的田野）呢？”
And I said, oh, Lester, thank you, thank you so much. And that's what made it in the episode, because I can't say hand-tealed field. You can't do it. I can't do it. Can you say hand-until field? Hand-until field. Anyway, that is how Lester rescued me in this scene. That's beautiful.
我说：“噢，莱斯特，谢谢你，太谢谢你了。”这就是最后进入正片的那一版，因为我实在说不出“hand-tealed field”。你做不到。我做不到。你能说“hand-until field”吗？Hand-until field。总之，这就是莱斯特在那场戏里拯救我的经过。太美妙了。
I know. He saved me with hand-plowed, bless his heart. He did. We need to talk about this scene, which we did talk about with Stephen, the role-play scene. William Butlerker. Yes. We basically covered this with Stephen, but we did have a fan question from Danielle,
我知道。他用“hand-plowed”拯救了我，上帝保佑他。他真的救了。我们得聊聊这场戏，也就是我们跟史蒂芬聊过的角色扮演那场戏。威廉·巴特勒·克（William Butlerker）。是的。我们基本上跟史蒂芬讨论过这个，但我们确实收到了来自丹妮尔、
Alison Stella, and Alison, who wanted to know how much of this scene was improv and how much was scripted. So I went and looked in the script. Thank you, Jamesapedia. Yes, thank you, Jamesapedia. The scene is entirely scripted. It's amazing. That is such good writing.
艾莉森·斯特拉和艾莉森的粉丝提问，他们想知道这场戏有多少是即兴发挥，有多少是剧本写好的。所以我去查了剧本。谢谢詹姆斯百科（Jamesapedia）。是的，谢谢詹姆斯百科。这场戏完全是按剧本演的。太惊人了。这写得太好了。
It is such good writing. I was sure that Steve's little asides were improvised. His delivery is so spontaneous. Like when he says, it's up to you to change his mind. Yes. I thought that was an improv, too. Scripted. Beautiful.
这写得太好了。我当时确信史蒂夫的那些小旁白是即兴发挥的。他的演绎太自然了。就像他说：“这得由你来改变他的主意。”是的。我以为那也是即兴的。剧本写的。太美妙了。
So, so good. What wasn't in the script was, I am, I rate right now. That was not in the script. And there were a couple of other little lines, but they were always just like a play on what was already there. But yeah, that scene is just beautiful. Next is a scene that we didn't talk about with Stephen, and I wish we had. It's that moment when Dwight peels his car out and tells Jim to get in.
真的，太棒了。不在剧本里的是：我现在气炸了。那不在剧本里。还有其他几句小台词，但它们基本上只是对已有台词的顺势发挥。不过，是的，那场戏简直太美妙了。接下来是一场我们没有跟史蒂芬聊过的戏，但我真希望我们聊了。那是德怀特猛踩油门倒车掉头（peels out）并叫吉姆上车的那一刻。
Jenna, I know. I meant to ask him about it. So he talked about it in the DVD commentary that he loved how absurd it was that Dwight was like, get in and then peels out. And you really think they're going to just tear out of the parking lot and go somewhere. And then they go nowhere. And then he wanted him to make like a hard left and just go into his parking spot. And Jim's like, what?
简，我知道。我本来打算问他这件事的。所以他在DVD评论音轨里谈到过，他很喜欢德怀特说“上车”然后猛踩油门掉头这种荒谬感。你真的以为他们要冲出停车场去某个地方。然后他们根本没去哪儿。接着他想让吉姆来个急左转，直接开进他的停车位。吉姆说：什么？
And Stephen said he wanted it to be even bigger. He was like, can we do an even bigger peel out, but there just wasn't the space. Well, I found this interview with Lester where he said that originally they were just going to have them meet, that Dwight was just going to have them meet down in the parking lot. And they were going to have this conversation. And that Stephen pitched, oh, guys, let's make it more interesting and do this crazy car maneuver. It's so funny.
史蒂芬说他希望这个动作能更大一些。他说：“我们可以再来个更大一点的猛踩油门掉头吗，但实在没有空间。”好吧，我找到了这篇关于莱斯特的采访，他说原本他们只是打算让两人碰面，德怀特只是打算在停车场跟吉姆碰头。然后他们要进行这段对话。是史蒂芬提议说：“哦，伙计们，我们把它弄得更有趣一点，做这个疯狂的汽车特技吧。”这太搞笑了。
So, so, so funny. I did get a fan catch from Madeline R. She is pretty sure that Pam's car is in the parking lot. Oh, that's a good catch in this scene. So I looked for it and it's so fast. I couldn't register it, but I bet, you know, they just would leave our cars there. Yeah. So I think there's a good chance it's there.
所以，所以，所以好笑。我确实收到了来自玛德琳·R的粉丝抓包。她非常确定帕姆的车当时在停车场里。哦，这场戏里这是一个很好的细节捕捉。所以我找了一下，它真的太快了。我没注意到，但我敢打赌，你知道的，他们只会把车留在那里。所以我觉得那辆车在那里的大概率是有的。
Oh, for sure. I bet. Well, you know, one of the things I loved about this scene was Dwight is, you know, convinced someone might be listening into their conversation. So he plays Jay Giles' band, the song, Centerfold, really loud. It just took me back. Where are my roller skates? I went and listened to the album last night and you guys, if you haven't watched music
哦，肯定的。我敢打赌。好吧，你知道的，我在这场戏里最喜欢的事情之一就是德怀特确信有人在偷听他们的对话。所以他把J·盖尔斯乐队（J. Geils Band）的歌曲《Centerfold》放得很大声。这一下子把我带回去了。我的旱冰鞋呢？我昨晚去听了那张专辑，伙计们，如果你们没有看过那个时期的音乐
videos from this time, go back. They're pretty special. They're real special. They're delightful. My kids were like, what are they doing? I'm like, you guys, this is a music video. Oh my gosh. I remember watching music videos on MTV.
录像带，回去看看吧。它们相当特别。它们真的很特别。它们太逗了。我的孩子们问：“他们在干什么？”我说：“伙计们，这是音乐录影带。”噢天哪。我记得以前在MTV上看音乐录影带。
And then do you remember the VH1 pop-up thing? Yeah. Where they would pop up little facts on the screen? Yeah, I loved those. Me too. The whole generation grew up watching music videos. Mm-hmm. It's wild.
然后你们还记得VH1的弹出式冷知识节目吗？是的。他们在屏幕上弹小冷知识的那种？对，我超喜欢那些。我也是。整整一代人都是看着音乐录影带长大的。嗯哼。太疯狂了。
So now we're back in the office and Dwight is on a sales call, but he becomes increasingly convinced that someone is listening to him. He's talking to a guy on the phone who, by the way, I found out was played by actor Steve Zissis, who if you don't know who he is, he is amazing. He is one of the stars of the movie Baghead, which he made with the Duplass brothers. Then he went on to create the TV comedy Togetherness with them. And he has a story by credit on the new film Cruella. I mean, he's part of that whole like mumblecore movement.
现在我们回到了办公室，德怀特正在进行销售通话，但他越来越确信有人在偷听他。他在电话里跟一个人说话，顺便说一句，我发现扮演者是演员史蒂夫·齐西斯（Steve Zissis）。如果你不知道他是谁，他真的很厉害。他是电影《畸形屋》（Baghead）的主演之一，这部电影是他跟杜普拉斯兄弟（Duplass brothers）一起制作的。后来他跟他们一起创作了电视剧喜剧《患难与共》（Togetherness）。他还在新电影《黑白魔女库伊拉》（Cruella）中拥有编剧署名。我的意思是，他是整个那种“微型独立电影”（mumblecore）运动的一部分。
We got the best actors just to be voices on the phone. What the hell? What the heck? Dwight is positive. It's Kelly, and he charges back there, right? Yes. And he finds her on the phone and she's like, you can't just come into my nook and call me stupid.
我们找来最好的演员只在电话里献声。搞什么鬼？见鬼！德怀特坚信那是凯莉，他气势汹汹地冲了过去，对吧？是的。他发现她在打电话，而她说：“你不能随随便便走进我的小角落然后叫我蠢货。”
Get out of my nook. And then Pam over at the corporate offices goes, that's what she said, that's what she said. Okay, that was an improvised pitch by John Krasinski. Oh, cute. So I'm there and John is like, oh my gosh, it should be a that's what she said, that's what she said. And so we did it, we saved it.
滚出我的小角落。然后公司办公室里的帕姆喊道：“这话她说过，这话她说过。”好吧，那是约翰·卡拉辛斯基（John Krasinski）即兴想出来的包袱。哦，太可爱了。所以我当时在那儿，约翰就说：“噢天哪，这应该是一句‘这话她说过，这话她说过’。”于是我们就这么演了，我们保留了它。
And then when I went to the corporate offices, we shot my side of it. That is so cute. I love that. Well, they're about to really uncover some details here in this little mystery, because Jim has a conversation with Kelly and she doesn't have anything to say. He literally asked her about Daryl. Like normally she'd be chatty and Pam is like, wait a second. Yeah.
然后当我去了公司办公室时，我拍了我那一侧的镜头。这太可爱了。我喜欢。好吧，在这场小小的悬疑中，他们马上就要揭开一些细节了，因为吉姆跟凯莉谈话，而她什么也没说。他甚至主动问起达里尔。按常理她应该喋喋不休才对，而帕姆说：“等一下。”是的。
Why isn't she talking your ear off? You know, it's a good thing that Pam was in Jim's ear this day because he may have never figured this out without her, truly. You know what I mean? Well, the next scene really cracked me up because Jim goes to Ryan. Ryan's got to know what's up with Kelly, right? And Ryan, I fell in love with Ryan in this episode, Jenna. Yeah, you're with me now.
她怎么没烦死你？你知道的，幸亏帕姆这天在吉姆的耳机里，如果没有她，他可能永远也搞不明白这一点，真的。你知道我的意思吗？好吧，接下来的场景真的把我逗乐了，因为吉姆去找瑞安。瑞安肯定知道凯莉出了什么事，对吧？结果瑞安——我在这一集里爱上了瑞安，简。是的，你现在跟我站在同一战线了。
I'm with you. I'm with you. Because Ryan said, hit this baby laugh. He says, I don't play the politics game anymore, Jim. Can I tell you something? I played it full on in New York. I played it high stakes for keeps, made it to the top. Like, who is this guy?
我跟你站在一起。我跟你站在一起。因为瑞安说，听听这个宝贝的笑声。他说：“我再也不玩政治游戏了，吉姆。我能告诉你一件事吗？我在纽约时可是火力全开地玩。我玩的是高风险、拼尽全力，一路爬到了顶端。”这人是谁啊？
And my favorite thing is he's like, can I tell you what I learned as he takes a sip of coffee? So we never end up finding out what he learned. I'm so sad. I would love to know his lessons. But Jim sees the coffee mug. Yes. This is the Colombo starting to piece it together like Steven talked about.
我最喜欢的是，他说：“我能告诉你我学到了什么吗？”同时他喝了一口咖啡。所以我们最后也没能知道他学到了什么。我太伤心了。我很想知道他的人生教训。但吉姆看到了那个咖啡杯。是的。这就是顶尖神探（Columbo）开始把线索拼凑起来的过程，就像史蒂芬说的那样。
Yes. He also has a coffee mug with his face and the little star. And that's when it becomes clear that Jim and Dwight did not attend Kelly's America's Got Talent viewing party. These were the party favors. These were the party favors and somewhere in her house, Kelly has a mug with Dwight's face on it and Jim's. She probably smashed them.
是的。他也有一个印着自己脸和星星的咖啡杯。就在那时，一切都明了了：吉姆和德怀特根本没有去参加凯莉的《美国达人》观影派对。这些就是派对伴手礼。这些是派对伴手礼，在她的某个地方，凯莉家里肯定有一个印着德怀特脸的杯子，还有吉姆的。她大概把它们都砸了吧。
Oh, I didn't even think about that. Oh, yeah. She bought everyone mugs. And so these leftover mugs are sitting there just making her so angry every day. And she's finally, oh, revenge is a dish best served cold, Kelly. Well done. I know. Well, I want you to know Jim figures it out.
噢，我都没想到这一点。噢，是的。她给每个人都买了一个杯子。所以这些剩下的杯子就摆在那里，每天都让她气得不行。她终于，哦，复仇是需要冷盘端上的菜，凯莉。干得漂亮。我知道。好吧，我想让你们知道吉姆弄明白了。
He rushes over to Dwight and says, Dwight, you were right, and I loved this scene so much. Mm-hmm. Dwight is finally right about a conspiracy. And then like a 10-year-old boy, he's like, let's go get her. And Jim's like, wait. But first, he does that crazy air kick at Phyllis. I know.
他冲向德怀特说：“德怀特，你是对的。”我太喜欢这一场戏了。嗯哼。德怀特终于在某次阴谋论上猜对了。然后像个10岁的小男孩一样，他说：“我们去收拾她。”吉姆说：“等等。”但在那之前，他冲着菲利斯做了一个疯狂的空中踢腿。我知道。
Well, also in that interview with Lester, he said that Rain improvised that air kick. He only did it one time, but it was so brilliant. That's the take they used. Of course he did. Because if you guys watch the show, Dwight does that air kick whenever he gets real excited. He's done it in the stairwell for a big sales call. It's the happy air kick. Yeah.
好吧，在对莱斯特的采访中，他还提到雷恩（Rainn）那个空中踢腿是即兴发挥的。他只做了一次，但实在是太精彩了。他们用的就是那个镜头。他当然会这么做。因为如果你们看过这部剧，德怀特每次一兴奋就会做那个空中踢腿。他在楼梯间为一笔大买卖打电话时也做过。这就是开心的空中踢腿。是的。
I'm going to start using it. Pump it up. Air kick. Also in that interview with Lester, he said he was really proud of this mug idea. And he said that ultimately the writers knew that Kelly was going to sabotage the customer surveys because Dwight and Jim skipped her viewing party, but they couldn't figure out how the guys would realize this fact. They had originally talked about maybe having Dwight tap Kelly's phone and overhear something,
我也要开始用这个了。嗨起来。空中踢腿。同样在那次对莱斯特的采访中，他说他对这个杯子创意感到非常骄傲。并且他说编剧们最终知道凯莉会破坏客户满意度调查，因为德怀特和吉姆跳过了她的观影派对，但他们一直想不出这两个家伙是怎么意识到这一事实的。他们最初讨论过让德怀特窃听凯莉的电话并无意中听到某些内容，
or maybe they would find like a secret recording device or something. But that's when Lester got the party favor mug idea. And it's really so genius. And then paired with the way Stephen directed it is just so great. Yeah. Two great people working together making a great moment. Yeah. I also got a fan question about this scene from Evan L. Did the cast do a photo shoot
或者他们可能会找到类似于秘密录音设备之类东西。但就在那时，莱斯特想出了派对伴手礼杯子的点子。这真的是太天才了。再加上史蒂芬执导的方式，简直太棒了。是的。两个伟大的人在一起合作，造就了一个伟大的时刻。是的。我还收到了一条关于这场戏的粉丝提问，来自埃文·L（Evan L.）。演员们为这些杯子拍过照片吗？
for the mugs? And if so, did they ask you guys to make weird faces because Oscar looks really bored on his? I don't remember a special photo shoot. We had done a publicity photo shoot. So maybe they use those images, but I'm looking at my face on the mug right now. And it's also possible that Phil just walked around and snapped pictures of us. It kind of looks like one of your publicity photos that maybe they color enhanced.
如果是的话，他们是不是要求你们做一些奇怪的表情，因为奥斯卡在杯子上的表情看起来真的很无聊？我不记得有什么专门的拍照。我们拍过宣传照。所以也许他们用了那些图片，但我现在正看着杯子上我自己的脸。也有可能菲尔（Phil）只是四处走动，抓拍了我们的照片。它看起来有点像你的宣传照片，可能是经过颜色增强的。
I still have my publicity photo. Do you want me to do a side by side in stories? Yes. We'll vote guys. Do you think it's the same picture? Or do you think Phil just took my picture at my desk one day? Because they did do that sometimes. Oh, they would.
我还留着我的宣传照片呢。你想让我在快讯（stories）里做一个对比吗？好啊。我们来投票吧，伙计们。你们觉得这是同一张照片吗？还是觉得菲尔有一天只是在我的办公桌旁拍了我的照片？因为他们有时确实会那样做。哦，他们会的。
They would walk around and you'd just be sitting there and they'd snap a picture of you. For something. We'll get to the bottom of it. Well, Jenna, Kelly is going to get called into Michael's office and she's busted now. She is. Dwight once are fired. Yeah. Michael asked them to leave the office.
他们会四处走动，而你可能就坐在那儿，他们就会“咔嚓”拍下你的照片。为了某种用途。我们会弄个水落石出的。好吧，简，凯莉要被叫进迈克尔的办公室了，她现在被抓包了。是的。德怀特希望她被解雇。是的。迈克尔让她离开办公室。
You know, he's like, this is serious. I need you to leave the office. And then Michael says this and I loved it so much. Michael says, I have an enormous amount of trouble trying to get people to come to my place and I hate it. I can't tell you how much leftover guacamole I've ended up eating over the years. I don't even know why I make it in such great quantities. And then he says, listen, just sit there and pretend to cry, right?
你知道的，他说：“这很严重。我需要你们离开办公室。”然后迈克尔说了这样一段话，我太喜欢了。迈克尔说：“我费了九牛二虎之力想让人来我家，但我讨厌这样。我无法形容这些年来我最终吃掉了多少吃剩的鳄梨酱（guacamole）。我都不知道为什么我要做这么大分量的。”接着他说：“听着，你就坐在那里假装哭，好吗？”
Can you do that? Yeah. And then they both end up laughing. That's a really sweet moment. It really is. And we got a bunch of people writing in to ask if that laugh after Kelly fake cries, if that was like a fake laugh or if Mindy broke. No, that was scripted.
你能做到吗？是的。然后他们两个最后都笑场了。那真的是一个非常温馨的时刻。确实如此。我们收到了一堆人写信来问，凯莉假哭之后的那阵笑声，到底是假笑还是明迪笑场了。不，那是剧本写好的。
It's scripted that her fake crying made them laugh. Well, I'll say this in re-watching this episode like three times, right? Before today, I could hear Mindy's fake laugh and then her real laugh. Yeah. So if you watch it, she fake cries, she fake laughs, then Steve laughs as Michael and then Mindy laughs as herself. Yeah. Her real laugh definitely comes out.
剧本里写的就是她假哭引发了大家的笑声。好吧，我会在重看这一集大约三遍之后说，对吧？今天之前，我能听到明迪的假笑，然后是她的真笑。是的。所以如果你看的话，她先是假哭，然后假笑，接着史蒂夫作为迈克尔笑了，然后明迪作为她自己笑了。是的。她的真笑绝对是流露出来了。
Yeah. So now we're at this scene at corporate, which we talked about a lot with Steven. This scene where Alex comes to Pam's work, he's going to kidnap her, wants to see this art. He said wine and cheese, okay? That's all you got to hear. Midday. Midday, there's an exhibit with wine and cheese, that's not being friends.
是的。现在我们来到了公司办公室的这场戏，我们跟史蒂芬详细聊过这个。在这场戏里，亚历克斯来到帕姆的工作单位，他要“绑架”她，想看她的艺术作品。他说有红酒和奶酪，对吧？你只需要听到这个就行了。大白天。大白天，有个带红酒和奶酪的展览，那可不叫当朋友。
Yeah. Well, thanks to James Apedia, I saw all of the candy bag for this. How many were there? 10. 10 alts for this scene. Yes. Oh, my word. Yeah.
是的。好吧，多亏了詹姆斯百科，我看到了这场戏的所有备用剧本（candy bag）。有多少个？10个。10个备选方案。天哪。是的。
I wanted to count because we kind of talked about it and it was 10, 10 alternate scenes and I swear we shot so many, so many versions of it. And I remember doing these scenes with Rich. It was so grueling. And we really bonded, like Rich and I are great friends today, I think because we went through this moment together. Yeah, you were in the trenches of trying to find this scene. Yes.
我想数一下，因为我们之前聊过，总共有10个备用场景，我敢发誓我们拍了无数个、无数个版本的戏。我记得和里奇（Rich）一起拍这些戏。那太折磨人了。我们真的建立起了深厚的感情，比如里奇和我在今天成了好朋友，我想就是因为我们一起经历了这段时光。是的，你们当时在努力寻找这场戏感觉的战壕里。是的。
Well, we should have Rich on and talk about it. We need to hear his side of things. We do. Of shooting this crazy scene. Let's call him, Rich, come on. So I feel like we really covered this, but we did have a fan write in and I'm so sorry it didn't write down your name because I thought this was a really good observation. They were saying, wasn't Pam's art program three months long and she went at the beginning
嗯，我们应该请里奇来聊聊这件事。我们得听听他的说法。确实得听。关于拍这场疯狂戏码的说法。我们给他打电话吧，里奇，快来吧。我觉得我们已经讨论得很充分了，不过确实有粉丝来信——很抱歉我没记下你的名字，因为我觉得这个发现真的很好。他们说，潘的艺术项目不是三个月吗，而且她是初...
of the summer? How was she there for Halloween and how is she still there? Isn't it November now? Art school is a mystery. It's a mystery. Yeah. Yeah. That's a good catch.
夏天开始的时候去的？她怎么能在那里过万圣节，又怎么会还在那里？现在难道不是十一月吗？艺术学校真是个谜。真是个谜。是的。没错。这个细节抓得真好。
I still want to know if she has parking. You know, these are things we're going to wonder about art school. Well, she's having to go into Manhattan for her corporate job because Pratt's out in Brooklyn. Well, we end this episode with Andy, Angela and Dwight because Andy has found the perfect place for them to get married and it shrewd farms. It ticks all of the boxes. Angela gave him a list of what the wedding location had to include.
我还是想知道她有没有停车位。你知道的，这些都是我们会对艺术学校产生的好奇。嗯，她得去曼哈顿做她的公司工作，因为普瑞特学院在布鲁克林。好吧，我们在安迪、安吉拉和德怀特的剧情中结束了这一集，因为安迪为他们找到了结婚的完美地点，就在舒鲁德农场。它符合所有的条件。安吉拉给了他一份婚礼场地必须包含的清单。
Yeah. And Dwight tells them he thinks they should have the Excalibur package. It's going to have everything they need. Angela is clearly delighted. Andy is relieved. And Jenna, all I could think of when I watched the scene was Jim and Pam planned Pam's wedding to Roy. And now Angela and Dwight are going to plan her wedding to Andy.
是的。德怀特告诉他们，他认为他们应该选择“石中剑”套餐。里面会有他们需要的一切。安吉拉显然很高兴。安迪如释重负。珍娜，我看这场戏时脑子里想的全是，吉姆和潘曾帮潘筹办她和罗伊的婚礼。现在安吉拉和德怀特要帮她筹办她和安迪的婚礼。
Oh, yeah. Right? Yeah. It's sort of a callback. It is. You know, there's another little weird callback in this scene. A lot of people wrote in with this fan catch that the funeral homes director in Job Fair. Yes, he's in the album.
哦，对啊。对吧？是的。这算是一个小小的呼应。确实是。你知道，这场戏里还有另一个有点奇怪的呼应。很多人写信指出这个粉丝彩蛋：在《招聘会》里那个殡仪馆馆长。对，他在那个相册里。
He's in the album. He got married at Shrewd Farms. Yes. Well, Lester said in his interview that they loved this guy and they used him twice and they also thought it worked because the shrewds get married in their own graves. So he felt that he would know about Shrewd Farms. Yeah. That's a great catch.
他在相册里。他在舒鲁德农场结了婚。是的，莱斯特在采访中说他们非常喜欢这个人，用了他两次，他们还觉得这样很合适，因为舒鲁德家族的人习惯在自己的墓地里结婚。所以他觉得这个人会知道舒鲁德农场。是的。这个细节抓得太好了。
Well, all righty, Dwighty. That was customer survey. Thank you so much, James Carey, for sending me those scripts. I also got in touch with Randy Cordray on this one because I couldn't remember if the Bluetooth's were real. I was so convinced. So I wrote Randy and I was like, they weren't real. No, they weren't real.
好吧，好啦，小德怀特。这就是客户调查。非常感谢詹姆斯·凯里给我发了这些剧本。这一集我还联系了兰迪·科德雷，因为我记不清蓝牙耳机是不是真的了。我当时深信不疑。所以我写信给兰迪问他们是不是真的，结果不是，它们不是真的。
They talked about it quite a bit on the DVD commentary. And of course, a humongous thank you to Stephen Merchant. We love you. We love you. Please come back. Yes. And next week we have business trip. Michael's going to Canada, y'all.
他们在DVD评论音轨里讨论过好几次。当然，还要极其感谢斯蒂芬·莫昌特。我们爱你。我们爱你。请再来吧。好的，下周我们要播《出差》。迈克尔要去加拿大了，各位。
And Rich, we're going to call you. Yes, Rich, you will be in business trip, an episode that your character does not appear. But we have questions for you. We do. And this is our podcast so we can do that. That's right. All righty, Dwighty, you guys have a good week. You are really loving that phrase.
还有里奇，我们要给你打电话。是的，里奇，你会在《出差》这一集里出现——尽管你的角色并没有在这一集里露面。但我们有问题要问你。是的，我们要问。这是我们的播客，所以我们说了算。没错。好了，小德怀特，大家过个好周。你真的很喜欢那个短语。
I said it one time too many, didn't I? Maybe, but I like that when you attach to something, you go for it. Thank you. All right. We'll see you next week. That was your extra long goodbye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey.
我是不是说得太多次了？也许吧，但我喜欢你一旦对什么东西上心，就会全力以赴的性格。谢谢。好的。我们下周见。这就是你那超长的告别。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。
Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的助理制作人是艾因斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。要收听无广告版的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用Stitcher Premium一个月，请使用兑换码OFFICE。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。